so I I don't know how many years ago it
was Twitter was like everywhere
everybody's talking about Twitter
Twitter's kind of dying off now
everybody's kind of gone over to
Instagram no I think but I'm still on
Twitter well I'm on Instagram too but
it's not me it's my social media team
they make me look a lot nicer and less
sarcastic than I really am so uh but
anyway Twitter is more like mean stuff
and nasty and I kind of think that's why
I like Twitter it's like I can do my
sarcasm on there and just get in a fight
with somebody it's fun and I'll stir it
up on there occasionally and I've really
really you know so anyway but the
downside about Twitter is is that people
who don't have real courage the only
courage they have his digital courage
they hide behind not their real name and
they just say stuff and James thinks
it's funny my producer so he collects
mean tweets about Dave they're really
not hard to find there's a lot of them
it's like the hate mail around here we
can bail it so the problem in this
culture is if you have an opinion be
ready somebody's pissed off instantly so
there you go all right Tyson says name
something everyone is obsessed with that
you don't get why me Dave Ramsey Jason
says Dave Ramsey comes from a long line
of financial people that prey on
people's fear plus laziness about the
occasionally confusing world of finance
however the word prey Jason is not
spelled in that methodology PRA why it
would be PR e why if I'm going to prey
on someone it's a y if I pray for
someone it's a Y I'll help you out with
that okay well there's an education
issue in America took anyway Ellen says
I'm glad you asked Dave Ramsey is the
biggest guilty pleasure
he's very motivational but doesn't give
the best advice so auction morning and
gets mad when you don't follow it number
one guilty pleasure okay there you go
Wolverine Co what is a Wolverine Co
that's someone who likes Michigan and
the Denver Broncos I just made that up I
have no idea I don't know what a
Wolverine coach dave ramsey has never
passed a financial course he specializes
and is good in getting people out of
debt but it's not qualified to give
financial advice concerning accumulation
or retirement legally oh okay
well I'll help you with that I actually
have a degree in finance I have had a
securities license and insurance license
a real estate license
hey and about seventy three other
designations after my name is indicate I
actually did pass a course or two but
either way Schuyler says I'm just
letting you know that my credit score
went up 71 points just from buying
everything with my credit card and
paying it off time paying it off on time
so cuss word Dave Ramsey I'll just leave
it at that okay okay Elizabeth every
time I mention anything about investing
to people they try to make me listen to
Dave Ramsey maybe don't trust people to
give financial advice if they themselves
don't have enough self-control to use
credit cards
yeah that's an indicator of ability to
give advice you send Cal crypto
obviously a Bitcoin fan says Dave Ramsey
is really stupid he is the idiot because
I was calling people investing in
Bitcoin with their student loans one in
five if you didn't know 21% of people
taking out student loans are putting the
student loan money into Bitcoin that's
like stupid squared okay Socialist
Republic of the moon this is the name of
your Twitter account I think we got a
hint on several fronts already okay Dave
Ramsey is a fraud who actively preys on
elderly religious folks with disposable
incomes to subsidize the money he also
gets from think tanks and insurance
companies wow you did spell praise
correctly it is PR ey good job on that
no money from think tanks I do have some
insurance companies that in that we
endorse that pea Saveur ties McPhee's
and elderly religious folks I guess if
you're if you're 12 then everyone older
than you is elderly so there you go
that's how it works right Leo says I
think I think the reason these Dave
Ramsey books won't work is cuz I'm not a
Christian no Leo they won't work cuz
you're not working the plan Mac says
Dave Ramsey's not-so-subtle arrogance
makes me so angry well it's just part of
the deal max about being on Twitter John
says listening to Dave Ramsey once again
I'm depressed
yes you can be debt-free if you make 180
thousand dollars a year and sell your
second home I paid all fifty thousand
dollars in six months by selling our
second home well no duh
John you're trying to be a victim it's
not gonna work for you popcorn vendor
says Dave Ramsey is an arrogant blowhard
that knows nothing about money my golden
retriever agrees okay Seth says this
year for Halloween I want to go to Dave
Ramsey's house dressed like a credit
card bring it man I'll give you some
candy candy to everybody that comes oh
my goodness that's fun stuff sort of
open phones at Triple Eight 8 to 5 5 to
25 there is a 12th episode there that's
volume 12 he James put it at the top of
the paper so I would know volume 12 of
Dave reads mean tweets